I have a question for you guys so let's
suppose you both have children right and
you see that they're very talented
they're great performers they're funny
they can sing they can dance they're
very artistic and creative but then they
tell you no I don't want to pursue that
I want to be a surgical tech or I want
to be a postman so the opposite a
postman yeah like I want to be a mailman
I want to be which is what our parents
wanted for us when we say okay I want to
be an actor or a singer this yes would
you do would you support your kid then
or would you know this is what you're
okay with that yes I got first place in
a talent show
yes but I won't be a postman yeah all
right well you don't want any money or
[ __ ] you don't want money or [ __ ] just
ask me to answer me that question it was
if my kid right was like Rachmaninoff a
musical prodigy yeah just killing it
right he's like I wanna be I want to
bless the boy at PF Changs that's my
dream yeah I would think that there was
something very seriously wrong with them
yeah but what if he was like I want to
be a teacher yeah for high school I want
to help kids thing is I would appreciate
that ambition in any child so if he has
an ambition to do anything like that's
enough because I meet kids nowadays you
say they're completely apathetic and
withdrawn
yeah and they have no ambition like
whatsoever they're just floating logs
yeah like but it's worse now I think
it's more like a I think it's harder for
your jet I feel like I'm the generation
above yours because I'm much older than
you are
I'm 46 okay hold it I'm old way older
that's and I feel like it's harder for
you guys though to make it in this
particular business because with the
internet and with YouTube you're now
competing with the world mm-hmm
you keep meeting with everyone and it's
not even really competing it's just like
there is no competition because there's
too many contestants you know what I
mean I could just not even it's
completely arbitrary and the landscape
changes
all the time ya know yeah we had vine a
couple of years ago yeah you know and
people like got famous off of that yeah
they definitely struck up a deal with
like summer's eve or something I mean I
got a call from a company they go can
you come we'd like to we signed a bunch
of vine stars and I go okay we just want
to have a meeting we want to propose
something to you so I drove down there
and they said there was like 20 vine
star zone then they go can you teach
them to do stand-up because we need to
make money we want to teach them to live
so Mike yeah they're really good in
their bedrooms in the middle of the
night in the middle of nowhere but when
you bring them out I think I think
people realize that slowly because like
they they're they're kids they're like a
little suburban kids that are going to
school yeah they just get a little
sleepover happy like what you know and
film it yeah but um yeah I mean I got
hopeful now that I was it kind of pisses
me off it does well I'll be yeah yeah
yeah I mean you should see I mean it cuz
I had to do it
I'm not saying but I had to do it in a
weirder way like in a more traditional
way it's I guess in many ways I had to
wait longer you know like it took me I
didn't get mad TV until I was in 30 yeah
yeah I mean I regret that it happened so
late for me but you look so young no I
always ears old she's getting younger
what you were like in when I met you at
that she's 20 yeah no I am good look at
your face though you have no [ __ ]
wrinkles or not that's your thanks yeah
yeah yeah young coconut over here yeah
um I still have resentments toward my
mom and dad but I love that are getting
yeah yeah yeah
I mean they'll never really get it
because but but that's not why they
don't need to get it don't you know
[Music]